[Applause]
so the cast is so wonderfully fantastic
and large so we booked you guys up into
two parts today yeah cami was gonna be
with us but we're Sh she was doing a
kick-ass women's panel she's a kick-ass
woman sure where she's here in spirit
but we're gonna get to that barchi scoop
so don't you worry guys here we are
season 3 of Riverdale and you guys are
now such a big deal that you fill up
Hall H tomorrow how does that make you
feel like whatever those the internet
last year with his sorority squat pose
really is really right yeah you did what
was that can you recreate we were all
leaning in front and you learned that
it's all about the lean down Holly H is
amazing I think we're incredibly excited
to do it yeah and and we're really
flattered to be H and then we can't wait
moderated by marks honey
Kelly was excited when she found out
that she was gonna be moderating what
was the first thing she told you I'm
moderating sit up straight did you help
her brainstorm with any questions no no
she knows more about season three did I
do
really yeah she spoke to Roberto she has
some some little tidbits well then share
a couple tidbits with me guys what
should fans expect from season three
okay Jake how you in jail man yes so we
start off Archie is on trial for the
murder of Cassidy Bullock he's innocent
he's innocent but you know you never
know what can happen and Rodell that's
the great thing about our show so we'll
see what happens at that
please tell me that veronica has been
visiting him while he's awaiting he
doesn't want her to but she's a good
girlfriend she she does she probably
will be coming to visit for sure but I
think you know the distance is gonna
shake things up a little between the two
mm-hm it was so great from to seeing
Marysol Hermione really take the power
back at the end of the year and really
show that you know ladies get things
done how are you gonna how are we gonna
see the dynamic between Hermione and
Hyrum moving forward I think with with
Hermione she can't show all her cards
now she even though she does have some
power now for herself she's gonna have
to navigate it very very carefully but
I'm really looking forward to seeing her
do that and kind of take him on even if
he may not know she's coming and I don't
know if this was necessarily intentional
but I was getting some flirty vibes
between Fred and Hermione in my soda
[Laughter]
I'm gonna feel about that he like well
as a fan of the show
I like remaining in Fred I think it's a
great relationship but as hirez doesn't
like any of that stuff between these two
in season two oh yeah in the first
episode the oculist
[ __ ] well you know as an avid
Riverdale fan I stopped all your
Instagram pages all your stories you
guys are so funny on the side and Kami's
pretty great he's very good he's pretty
great but I happen to see the lovely
Molly Ringwald getting on set Luke what
was I like to welcome back here on
screen wife well we always like seeing
Molly come back yeah especially cuz
she's a lawyer
we're gonna need one is that a conflict
of interest no I think you I don't think
so no no no no we play fast and loose
with the law in our town um do you think
we could ever see a Fred and Molly what
is Mary Mary oh my gosh sorry a friend
and Mary reunion no no I mean she
divorced me she had a good reason for it
I'm thinking and I haven't changed any
no I
know what that would be I respect your
honesty yeah that's right Abby Ashley my
love yes you know that I love Josie to
pieces I just got you as a pop Funko at
all how does it feel knowing that there
was a mini you now out there that she
purchased I thought it was I thought it
was cool enough just being cast in the
role and having like the the Riverdale
comic book come out based on the show I
was like oh this is so awesome they're
gonna be kids from now until forever
that are gonna see this type of Josie
and now I'm a little bubble head which
is you literally mean and you told me
you're gonna get one for your mom I am
my momma yeah love your biggest fan yeah
yeah but I need more Josie I need more
for singing and I want to bounce a
theory off of you right now okay I love
the Pussycats that we have met and come
to know and love for the past two
seasons yeah but as of now you know the
group the band broke up and we've seen
that both Cheryl and Veronica have
stepped in every now and then to be
pussycats could that ever be the new
trio um me speaking personally I hope
not really I hope not only because we
haven't gotten a chance to really see
melody and Valerie those characters
alone and though that is that that is
Josie and the Pussycats so I think it
would I just think it would be nice to
flesh that out a little bit more and if
it's not possible then maybe find I
don't know somebody else like I just
think that Cheryl is great doing what
she's doing
Veronica she's got a lot going on you
know I'd like to maybe do something a
little bit different I also want to see
a lot more of the hot dads of Riverdale
sharing scenes together yes I'm talking
about you two right there along without
time Sheriff Keller and FP can we expect
to see any more of the adult dads kind
of coming together yeah I think we
be working against each other and with
each other a little bit right sure yeah
attention yep you'd be arresting my
operation it was so great every time we
get to see you and machen share scene
together and more coming on I love those
scenes I think so I think that we're
gonna see actually more of the adults
together hmm then we've seen in the past
going into season three and that's
that's really fun for all of us just to
play together well and also because they
have such a shared deep history they
went to high school together said well
are there any questions that you guys
hope will get answered anything that you
yourself as an actor have always
wondered about your character yeah I
fight if I could do a flashback or
whatever someone mentioned it earlier
today I would want to see how Hyrum and
her like that love triangle to happen in
high school how that happened mm-hmm
curious about that KJ you and I are
talking and I know that you want to
share more scenes I know you want to
share more scenes with Cole is that
something that could happen this year we
talked about a little bit last year I
feel like I don't even know call
sometimes every time we have scenes
together we're yelling at each other
mm-hmm so be good to have like a scene
where we're just mates you know what I
mean like the boys but as of now I
haven't seen any of it but I think that
Josie and Archie become a little bit
closer this year if I recall maybe maybe
we're on episode 2 we'll just tell me
what was your reaction to the season 3
premiere so it's great it's great yeah
yeah that's really truly truly it's
really good we had our musical episode
last year could that be an annual thing
really yeah did you think no no no what
do you think you can't say you can sing
again
I know cannot sing it won't be happy
lastly what is the best tease that you
can give for the Riverdale fans out
there about this next season
are we gonna get a lot more of the the
south side kind of infusing themselves
into the north side you're smart you're
show on this or anything yeah North Side
south side war may be brewing hmm
maybe you know a lot of it yeah yeah you
know South Bay
oh I know stuff I'm just trying to use
my knowledge and beauty to you guys
because you know I think that Hermione
might have some serpent roots that we
need to explore that would be in season
one we are sitting around with FP and
making deals so obviously they have
straight I don't know I've talked to her
it covers that but we'll see you guys
thank you so much for chatting with me
and letting me try and get as many
spoilers out of you as I can have fun
yeah and thank you all so much to the
fans for tuning in
get excited for more Sweetwater secrets
which is our Riverdale after-show only
on e t--'s youtube channel thank you
guys so much let's go to the photo booth